bonjour tristan qui à vélo merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt france
alors on l'a dit un donald trump est à
l'origine du retrait des troupes
américaines en afghanistan mais
aujourd'hui c'est joe biden qui essuie
les critiques alors à qui la faute
oui vous avez tout à fait raison c'est
joe biden qui essuie des critiques ce
matin et il n'y a ce qui est vraiment
très frappant aux états unis en ce
moment s'il n'y a aucune voix pour
défendre
joe biden alors on pouvait vraiment s'y
attendre de la part de la droite de la
part du camp conservateur du camp
républicain il est vrai que fox news ce
matin il va très très fort contre contre
joe biden et ce qui est encore plus
surprenant c'est que le washington post
you say to day the wall street journal
qui est en général quand même assez
propre hayden assez mesuré à ces
centristes dans ses propos et bien sont
tous contre joe biden il n'y a aucune
voix même dans son propre camp en ce
moment dans les voies politiques
intellectuels universitaires aux états
unis pour le défendre donc la faute un
réellement dans le discours médiatique
lui revient proche exactement à joe
biden
lorsqu on reproche à dubaï tonnes ces
deux choses c'est d'abord de ne pas
avoir écouté ses conseillers qui lui
avait dit très très clairement que la
prise de kaboul était imminente dans la
prise de kaboul était tout à fait
imminente simplement lorsque l'on
écoutait les journalistes les gens qui
étaient présents sur place on le savait
que ça allait arriver et la deuxième le
deuxième reproche c'est de ne pas avoir
rétropédaler puisque depuis quelques
jours on demande des gens demandent les
conseillers demandent à ce que plus de
soldats sont envoyés et à ce que joe
biden en fait ordonne le non retrait des
forces américaines en afghanistan
vous parlez de rétropédalage on sait que
je vais y donne devra s'exprimer dans
dans quelques jours sur sur le sujet
est-ce que l'éventualité d'un
rétropédalage est possible
alors non joe boyd ne l'est déjà dit
blinken a déjà dit aussi il n'y aura pas
de rétropédalage les dans les rues de
retrait des troupes américaines est
athée ne vont pas rétro pédaler et ce
qui veut dire que l'on va être vraiment
là dans un engrenage de plus en plus
insoutenable pour les américains
précisément aussi des américains qui
regardent la télévision en ce moment
tous les jours et qui voit ses ces
images qui sont tout à fait désastreuses
pour leur pays moi je crois que c'est
quelque chose cette guerre milan était
terrible 1 pour un cours pour les
afghans je crois qu'il y aura des
répercussions qui seront
désastreuses pour joe biden sur le sol
américain avec son propre peuple alors
des répercussions pour joe biden c'est
une situation qui peut être entre
guillemets profite également à donald
trump non
ouais c'est une situation avec qui
profite à tous les opposants à dubaï
d'honneur qui profite bien évidemment à
donald trump au camp républicain aux 36
mhz elle ce matin déjà mais je suis pas
conne elle était sur le pont garde pour
dire que cette situation était tout à
fait désastreuses pour le pays il a même
parlé de rumeur qui dit ray kiki qui
établissent que l'état nippon pourrait m
l'ambassade des états unis à feu le 11
septembre prochain lors de
l'anniversaire du 11 septembre
2001 et puis aussi de l'autre côté la
cause de byden qui est tout à fait anti
militariste qui ne veut plus d'une
présence militaire forte en dehors en
dehors des états unis qui l'a aussi
profitent de cette situation pour un peu
regagné
une part du discours médiatique et
politique aux états unis est très
rapidement avant de se quitter tristan
kabelo comment on peut expliquer tout
simplement ses difficultés que l'on que
l'on connaît là on en afghanistan
comment on peut expliquer que ce retrait
américain elle soit finalement si
compliqué
ça c'est raide et facile à établir il
semblerait que cette situation est était
en fait déjà commenté et analysé par les
conseillers du président du président
biden il semblerait que il est établi
que kaboul tomberez très très très très
très rapidement et donc et donc ça se
passe exactement comme comme ce que les
prêts et les conseillers du président
biden avait avait avait établi en fait
merci beaucoup tristan kabelo d'avoir
été avec nous cet après midi je rappelle
que vous êtes maître de conférences en
civilisation américaine à l'université
john hopkins merci beaucoup